jean is with us in Binghamton New York
hi Jean how are you I'm very well thank
you I'm so grateful to be able to talk
to you you too what's up well I'm
calling for some motivation and some
advice because about a year ago I read
your book Total Money Makeover as an
irate financial piece revisited I was
able to get my husband to read it and I
was even able to get one of my daughters
to read Total Money Makeover he agrees
that it's time for us to get out of debt
but he doesn't quite agree on your plan
no I read it and it works for me so I'm
calling for some advice to find out how
we can kind of get on the same page to
get out of our debt and to eventually
get more into our retirement we have he
wants to go the route of a HELOC to at
least reduce the amount of interest that
we're paying and he wants to be able to
release the cars which are up in May and
July and I'm not interested in going
that way and I'm asking for a little
advice on that route so I didn't hear
anything he suggested that got you out
of that well you're releasing cars so
you're staying in that you're moving
your dad over onto your home and putting
your home at risk right and so you
didn't get out of that you just moved in
around since he read the book we
actually have gotten rid of some of the
credit cards and that debt and the debt
that's on that he's he's a numbers guy
and I'm not the numbers person and I
finally put on my big girl pants and
paid attention to everything that we
were doing and I I get it with the
stories that you tell and the
experiences that people that you've
helped and which is not quite seeing
eye-to-eye so well the problem with the
numbers guy is that he's dealing with
something that's hypothetical because
it's the only way his numbers work in
other words so far his best use of math
has gotten you into this mess you know
both of us it's both of us but I mean
you know honestly this is a broke guy
wanting to argue about how to get out of
that
like a fat guy trying to tell you how to
lose weight I don't really care if he's
a numbers guy his numbers suck I agree
you know and that that's the thing you
turn around and lease a car and you say
you're a numbers guy there's no way if
you're a numbers guy you crunch the
numbers on a car lease and think of it
anything but a fleece
it's a horrible deal it's a horrible
deal and so I mean know that that's just
I want to keep my cars and I'm trying to
act like I'm sophisticated when I want
to keep my cars but no you can't keep
the cars you're broke and obviously you
can't pay for him so now how to get him
to see that I don't know cuz right now
he's not listening to anybody he's got
an interesting level of arrogance to go
with his ignorance so you know I you
know I'm afraid if he called me I might
be rather tough on him is what I'm
saying
so that's probably not our answer how
did how can you get him to do this to
think differently you know I think first
thing is he has to realize you have a
vote for the first time in your all's
marriage you said you put on my big girl
pants I'm quoting you and my vote counts
in this and I'm not going along with
your numbers because your numbers have
brought us into this mess you and me
together using our best plan have
created a mess and so you and me
together need a different plan other
than you crunching numbers because
honestly there's nothing he described
here this get really helping you let me
give you an example of how dumb this is
okay how much money are we talking about
moving into the HELOC about $25,000 all
right and so what's your household
income approximately 135 times and you
don't have and both cars or least right
how much other debt do you have we have
about 22,000 in credit cards only about
49,000 left on our mortgage and about a
guesstimate of 10,000 and Parent PLUS
loans okay all right so you have 25
wanting to move on he's wanting to move
on to the heal on $10,000 in Parent PLUS
and you've got two cars right that are a
problem okay
and if we put $10,000 a piece on the car
replacement that's a $20,000 problem all
right so you make a hundred and thirty
five thousand dollars and you have a
$75,000 problem he's wanting to address
twenty five thousand of that by moving
it to a lock the he lock interest rate
should be in the five percent range does
that sound right I think he was quoting
me a different number he was quoting me
about zero point two nine five percent
interest I don't know where he got it
from I don't either
that if he's got a point a quarter of a
percent a third of a percent interest
rate on a HELOC that's wrong doesn't
exist there's nine he locks out there at
that so there's something wrong with
that quote that might be per month yeah
I don't know maybe it was a different
kind of loan I'm not sure yeah so here's
the deal let's say it's five percent is
an example all right and let's say these
loans are very one of these what's the
twenty five thousand borrowed against
what is that credit cards yes he'd like
to be able get rid of the credit card
that's the twenty five thousand okay so
if you let's say they're fifteen percent
okay okay fifteen and you move it and
you say and you move it down to five so
it saves you ten percent ten percent of
twenty five thousand 2,500 bucks okay
you don't have a $2,500 problem you have
a $75,000 problem you follow me
yes I do so you know this is um I mean
it's it's it's mathematically correct
but it's so small that it's
insignificant if you use this
methodology to get out of debt it's
going to take you four hundred years
mathematically so the methodology you
guys need to use is for once in your
life you need to say no we're not
by anything yes we're selling everything
yes we're going on we're going on beans
and rice rice and beans we're gonna live
like no one else we're not going on
vacation we're not gonna see the inside
of a restaurant we're gonna get a couple
of beater cars and get rid of these
stupid fleeced cars and we're gonna tear
up this debt fast hard and passionately
now that will move the needle as you
start talking about a seventy-five
thousand dollar debt on 135 thousand on
our income thirty-seven five not twenty
five hundred three 37,500 per year not
two thousand five hundred thirty seven
thousand five hundred per year in your
debt free in two years that's what
you're gonna have to do so this home
equity loans a joke mathematically says
one numbers guy to another numbers guy
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you are
not a victim you're not a victim of big
corporations you're not a victim of Wall
Street you're not a victim of capitalism
you're not a victim of wealth inequality
you're not a victim of racism you're not
a victim